c'est une tradition chaque 1er janvier
les règles changent et on sort la
calculette
côté bonnes nouvelles le barème de
l'impôt sur le revenu et réformes et
notamment pour les deux premières
tranches pour près de 17 millions de
foyers le gouvernement annonce des
économies se chiffrant jusqu'à 300 euros
huit foyers sur dix seront également
exonérés de la taxe d'habitation
ça va être dur pour les maires parce que
plus beaucoup d'argent pour aménager
leur fils
les vents pour les gens qui ça arrive
c'est bien pouvoir d'achat toujours le
smic augmente de 1,2 pour cent il est
fixé à 1500 39 euros cela représente 15
euros de plus par mois
2020 affichent des changements en
matière de santé ainsi l'instauration du
reste à charge 0 pour certaines paires
de lunettes et certaines prothèses
dentaires des modèles seront entièrement
remboursés mais certains pressentent
déjà que cela ne se fera pas sans
contrepartie
je pense qu'on va encore taxer les
mutuelles parce que ça des méthodes qui
traque et ça fait de plus en plus mal et
puis nous on va nous augmenter aussi des
mutuelles al'inverse l'homéopathie sera
moins bien remboursés à hauteur de 15%
les génériques quant à eux seront
favorisés seul le médecin pourra
prescrire les médicaments princeps et
dans des cas très encadrée pour les
dépenses courantes certaines grimpe
les timbres sont plus chers de 10% en
moyenne compter 97 centimes pour le
timbre vert près de la moitié des
banques devraient également augmenter
leurs frais selon un site spécialisé
seule exception les tarifs réglementés
du gaz qui vont baisser en moyenne de
0,9 pour cent en janvier sa baisse de
0,9 le mois prochain ça va peut-être
augmenter de 4 donc change rien on subit
dernière nouveauté de 2020 la fin des
objets en plastique à usage unique type
coton tige paille ou gobelet mais ce
geste pour la planète entrera en vigueur
progressivement un délai d'écoulement
des stocks sur six mois a été prévu par
le législateur